so i think everybody i do
n't know you have to ask other tennis players
antenna playerin i think
every tennis player and every
tennis player were suffering from size in some way and in
some way
and um the reason i
say that it's an individual sport and
you lose  every week that means you
have to be some kind of
illusion artist and
pretend to yourself that you can still do it
being a tennis pro is like being an entrepreneur
only with much much more ball felt
at least what you my take away after the
conversation with Andrea and she really is an
entrepreneur too  you really have to
say she not only has a tennis hall
behind her, this was successful number
9 in the world, she once earned almost 10
million in prize money, but is a
writer, moderator, of
all the tire partnerships and, above
all, she observes her environment
very closely because of that  We
talked a lot about why
tennis tournaments work Werder
earns money Grand Slam is how you
could get confused, so such aspects in the
end but the podcast was a lot of
fun, but that can be seen from the fact that
I think tennis is quite good and I
also like Andrea a lot, but just myself
straight into the conversation let's start with a
warm welcome Andrea
Petkovic hi thank you very much for letting me be here
so you're not a tennis player
anymore no I'm not officially a
tennis player anymore even if I
think so athlete artist
musician the things you
somehow stay for  it doesn’t matter whether you
’re officiallytired or not and you
started when you were six i
started when you were six i still play
and i still like to play
they invited me to the legends
doubles i can
write back i think i have to
There may be an error in the system but no, they
also wrote me back
here, fun, I took it
that the invitation didn’t come because of my
tennis player qualities,
but that’s okay, I don’t have an
ego, okay, but that’s what it means when
you then  because something positive
has been noticed over the years, then
you get written to if you
want to play there as a legend, yes, I think
it comes a little bit because I
work as a tennis expert and
analyst in America at Tennis Ch and have
had quite a few of them this year
made there there are the studios in
LA and and it's a lot of fun for me and
I think I got pretty good
feedback there for my analyzes that
was my strength when I was
still playing I was
n't the most talented athlete or
athletic  but I'm not the
most talented tennis player and I
was able to make up for a lot with
tactics through game plans that I had
just watched beforehand through videos
and determined analytically and I
was able to
do that  I think
that's how they
noticed me a bit Wimbledon because certainly
not because of my playing
qualities on grass I
played well but on grass it's not
necessarily my favorite surface in general
which always has to be anticipated your highest
placing vintage I think number 9
and your best was semi-finals  because in
Paris no and when it was formed I think
round three or four I was exactly that's
why it was also the
surprise when this invitation
came from Lashes I always reached small Grand Slams
several times the second week
played quarterfinals in all
semifinals at the French  Open so
really successful and
played consistently at the Grand Slams only in
Wimbledon I never made it past the
third round I was
once in the semifinals of the
doubles event in Wimbledon by mistake because I
had a very good partner who
dragged me through as a crutch  by her
side and I think that was the
first invitation I really
had officially because I resigned
and two weeks later I had the
invitation from Wimbledon in the inbox in the
e-mail inbox and I was
pretty sure it was a mistake  was but
I'm playing next week so it ca
n't have been a mistake to take a quick
look at how such a career starts so
you grew up in Darmstadt, so to speak.
Parents from Croatia ne um then
Yugoslavia my father is
myself my mother is Bosnian so
exactly the two you oh  man oh that's
okay no problem
but I always get confused what
is I think to
put it correctly I think
Djokovic is exactly correct then my
other that you can do so many good
athletes athletes from the corner then the
next one me  always follow is
the basketball player from the Mavericks
he is Slovenian ne exactly the Slovenian
and the akic is also a Serb exactly
one question we can now
just do the best you can never be
wrong from the then boys
why so I have the question why come
there resp  just before why are there so many
good athletes so I think
a lot has to do with the fact that
people are generally very tall and very
broad-minded and also muscular
so my father
turned 63 two days ago and he is
still as tall as me and  is
still on the
tennis court for eight hours, I just think that in
general it is a very sporty
nation and then of course it is often the case
in countries where the
economy is perhaps not that stable
and where there are not that many paths to
the elite  however the elite
means or gives out ways the
sport is and then as it
always is, the more successful
athletes there are in a country, the
more athletes there are
in the youth who then simply do this
and those of
the Tour de  France favorite just
followed are also the pogatscher where
does that gentleman Slovenia country how many
slovenes are there 3 million yes i think
3.5 what people come out so
how many your NBA play now
last then winter sportsmen partly also
croatia only has seven or
eight million people soccer really
good national soccer team so the
genetics are a bit something and then yes I
think a bit and I do
believe that this once you
see that you also umm you can see that
in Germany that there is always a
successful generation then that
inspired the next successful generation and
then you have these gaps in between where
a generation was missing and
I believe that this inspiration is passed on and on and on and on
and unfortunately it doesn't exist in the
Balkans yet it's getting better and better of course
they're also developing
these countries are of course progressing
more and more from week to week and year to year but they are
still the fastest way to the
top is still through sport
or
as a woman if you are very good looking and
become a model or something  I don't know either,
but that's natural, then of
course you have, of
course, you can also aim for Hollywood,
but then you have to
train your accent away and uh, all these things
Sport is the easiest way to
find out as quickly as possible,
okay, for me it's real
Phenomenon for many years, how can it
be that countries that are big like
Berlin bring out so many top
athletes and sometimes teams
and in the end you are also
a bit genetic at least an
example of that but until then
your father grew up in Darmstadt
trained and then you were when was it
clear that you could somehow become a real professional
a good question when was that clear I
think it was clear to me at around 13 14 that
this was going to be the path I
wanted to take in the life of a
tennis player and erm
Tennis players are so many wrong
tracks to overcome it's
a very
[music]
very
investment related sport in the sense that you
have to invest a lot to even
train to drive it's
mostly all over Europe and America
most of the tournaments are in Europe and
America  as a tennis player i pay for
everything myself my trips my hotels
my trainer you can say exactly i
am a solo trip entrepreneur and of
course a lot can go wrong i
am above all at the beginning
and i had a big advantage
that at 15 i was actually already very
similar  I looked the way I do now so
I was already very physically developed
had good muscles and I
could at 15 my parents didn't have
much money they couldn't afford for
me to travel around with a trainer or physio
let alone a physiotherapist or
fitness trainer I'm always on my
own to train  and
often it was then that I knew
before the tournament and this pressure
then of course also created an incredible
resilience in me from
I often knew before the tournament if I did
n't win the tournament I couldn't
go to the next tournament because then I would
n't  have the budget and next
the same argument your father
said in the SZ interview on Saturday, so
read about why Novak Djokovic is so
successful, he also said because he
had so little money at the beginning and he
had to win the small tournaments
to somehow get close
while western Spain or
Germany,
or other countries that are more prosperous,
tournaments often
award wildcards to such players in
these countries, while e.g. now less
well-known players from the Balkans
apparently didn't get it and
so obviously
Monster hat always had to fight for it  to
get into the tournaments at all and that was
at least your father's analysis, it was me
why he was so
harder, so mentally harder, I
didn't read it at all, I only
heard that a few people asked me about it,
I still have it  haven't
read the interview but i go there
i actually don't always go in front
with my father but there i go there
come with him with him because i know that
when i
think back on it i still get
such a chunk of fear in my chest
because it's for  It was such a stress and
pressure for me to know that I was traveling to a
tournament and if I did
n't win the tournament I couldn't travel to the
next tournament and that was
my dream of becoming a tennis pro and being
able to make a living from playing the WTA tournaments
that are WTA  In the category
then the tournaments that are really broadcast
on TV as professionals,
where you really
earn prize money and this
pressure I had
of course
made me very resilient afterwards, because when you are then in the
Grand Slam quarter-finals you will
either way make your prize money
then it's not as much pressure as if you
can outlast us i
wish i was playing in today's
generation i was in when
i played semifinal french open in
the grand slams that's where the most
prize money i think is  I think it
would be 250,000 euros today I don't think ten times
that ten times but I think today
for the semifinals you would 650 700,000
so I can look it up right
away I can calculate that afterwards it's
all officially visible you can
look at everything but I think
already that it is now about 13:04 times
so of course i was a bit
lazy maybe just the total courier
but look they are about
how many years then earned over 15 i
have 16 years i have let's say
14 years on the 2 years  I would
take for this Challenger Tour where you
really don't earn anything but
really just play your costs
if at all and then 14
years where I really played on the WTA Tour
where it
makes a difference and that's where you got
in  are in the WTA we do
something like 90 I was
19 I tore my cruciate ligament when I was 19
so I had to take another year off
and then when I was 20 I really
scored consistently then on the WTA and then
you are still solo twice
and  that you have to generate sales
but then you also have a
physio trainer all traveling with you, that
’s exactly what happens later,
I think that’s the next step in
the development of a tennis player
when you’re a professional and
then you’ve established yourself  and then it was
relatively clear at some point you
also know about your quality and I
then knew in about good years or in
very, very good years I ca
n't make the top ten, but I did that
two or three times in my career
I knew in the good
years I'm a top 30 player and in
the bad years I'm a top
60 player and then later as I
got older there were a few
other factors, then
of course the ability to regenerate decreases
and so on and so forth that comes  then
that's another factor of
age, you have to
feed that in somehow, but do you want to
say you've gotten everything out that
was definitely possible and that's
exactly what I wanted to say, then
this next step is then you will  you
also become an entrepreneur in a
way then you have to start with the money
you earn because as I said with us,
clubs or associations do not bear
the costs but we ourselves then
you have to start investing in yourself with the money that you
earn is
that  in nutritionist trainer
physiotherapist whatever you
can do to set up your body better to
strengthen your health to boost your immune system whatever there is
that you
can legally max out yes so
can make the most use of so where did
you say therapist  yes yes
medical that has my career I
had very early on I
also noticed that now of course I
am older and many
athletes have pursued careers
I have seen that many athletes who
had a major injury very early on that
the whole  carry along their whole career
and it was similar for me
because I think if I had a cruciate ligament tear when I was 18
or 219 and you
always compensate with the other
half of my body and it
always led to problems for me then at
some point I have cartilage damage in the
other  Knee got because I compensated with the
other side and that's
why for me this
investment in my medical
lineup in my physiotherapist
in my physiotherapist that I traveled
with a physiotherapist for a while,
that's how it was  the
most important thing for me in the end in the end
especially then of course
that was exactly how it was my team was mostly the
trainer
physiotherapist and sometimes when the
tours were so long there are
longer tours like e.g. in March is
the long
US tour that lasts like that  I also had 7 to 8 weeks
in the fitness trainer
where I knew it would be more difficult to
maintain fitness on my own.
I then had full-time employment with you, but
they were then full-time employment with me,
I then had to pay for the flights,
I had to pay for the hotels  Pay I have to pay for
the food
we ask ourselves okay how much
can I earn in the tournaments now
and how much does it cost me so
a beer mat how to start a
startup actually yes I
mostly did it in my head I
then I always had it like that  on the screen
roughly how much something will cost me and
then I knew if I got far in a
tournament I remember, especially
since I'll take an extreme
negative example in Indian worlds.
That was last year before I
stopped and I knew it would
work  towards the end and I
arrived with full trass so with a trainer
physiotherapist a lot of fitness trainer
and wanted to put everything in the last
year of my career and we were there
ten days earlier I
showed three hotel rooms we were there ten days
earlier in California the hotel room
cost $350 a night and the day
before the match I tore an adductor
and had to drop out of the tournament
and erm I do
n't get any prize money that means it all just kind of just
happened in the air
and then the question arose
Do I try to get fit on site
and try to play Miami for the
next tournament or do I go
home and cancel the whole thing and
then I decided to try Miami
because I knew it was my last year I
have to put everything in and have it
then spent another three weeks in the
USA with my whole entourage
trying to get fit but did
rehab every day went to the doctors
and so on and so on and
then got back to the in Miami two days before my
first match  same
place and also had to
pull out of the tournament so I didn't have any
prize money income in these four almost
four weeks because
otherwise in which they don't but
are there otherwise from time to time
entry fees
yes there are smaller tournaments with
These big tournaments are
called mentatory events on the tour,
which means you have to play them
regardless of
whether you want to or not, of course you ca
n't play, but then
you get a zero in the system, which means the
tournament is marked as 0  Points are counted in your
system and you lose in
the world rankings you get if you
are a top player you get a top 8 player
i.e. one of the first eight
seeded players
you also get a fine that
is between $100 and $200,000 and um
and that's why no city money is
paid there, it's done in smaller
tournaments where participation
is more or less voluntary and then of course entry fees are
paid so that big
stars can be attracted, but that also
played my role for you, didn't it, it
's just in  Tennis it's very very
simple it's strictly hierarchical
here your ranking is better the more
you are invited to tournaments the
more entry fee you can
claim the more bonus you get
on contracts with outfitters so it's
really quite simple that's why
it's now  For me it's also so confused in the
media world where he
can call up any numbers at random
if you want and if
someone is willing to pay them then
he does it and if not then he does
n't and in sports that's at
least in tennis of course me  I do
n't know how it is in other sports,
but of course in tennis there are
little things like, for example,
which market you come from, the German
market is of course stronger than a
Serbian compared to
a Novak Djokovic or an
American one is of course even
stronger
than now, for example, the German that
comes of course there are such
little things but in general the
beans are graded according to ranking made
according to world rankings and that’s how
the entry fees work now has
changed a bit through social
media
bring money or so
e.g. those with 18 or  19 won the US Open from
the source which was a huge
sensation
beautiful girl
woman talented
half Chinese half Romanian but plays
for England so covers a lot of markets
very eloquent so charming
really a great girl also just
a super super woman or young
woman who has  of course after the US Open she
hardly won any matches for a year
and her ranking kept
slipping slipping slipping but
of course she was able to via the followers
on her social media works with
big brands Christian Dior
Tiffanys I think British Airways and of
course she still has it  your
financial
these follower numbers I have
a scooter myself Paris we have to watched for the first
time and then talked to a few people
and everyone says they
are counting followers now
because tennis players are
totally relevant and then there was one who
was totally disappointed with Taylor Fritz
this American player who
no longer does a little more posting
and then he would have to get much better
deals, so apparently tennis has
now gone from being a game where it was really about
the sporting proceeds
to a sport, but it also has to be a lot
about social media in the end  almost
influenza can be solved yes so it has
really changed well I have to say
I've been for the last three four
years I stopped last year
and the last three four years of my
career I haven't been as
successful as I was in the prime of my career
between 20 and 30, where I
played regularly at a very high level, that’s why I did
n’t experience this hype in myself
like that anymore, of course,
I also know, through my colleagues, of course,
that things
have changed  and as a
mentor in the German Tennis Association, I am also
responsible for the young professionals, let's call
them the youngest is 18, the oldest
is 23, and of course I
now realize that I can play the whole thing again for
someone from the German Tennis Association
in the world  we have
really good ones could be the problem is
what it is compared to my
generation there are a lot, much fewer
so things really have to
go well if someone gets injured that
can always happen that would be super
sad because we don't have any more  as
many as we used to have, but the ones
we have are very good, especially Jule
Niemeyer, who
will also be playing in Wimbledon today,
by the way,
that the 23-year-old has great prospects for
the future and there is a
19-year-old here
by the way, comes from Hamburg on whom I rely a lot on you
I think that the right
number is called Nora Akku and has a
Gereonian background and um was
born here in Hamburg and
grew up here and has an amazing talent
and um is a really tough old one so
that  you rarely have today that's
really a tough role she fell at
the French Open
she got up played straight on she
came to my point of view didn't think it
was that bad she came to my side
her entire knee was open there was
blood and the referee
do you mean sonoma medical timeout
and the number she just
angled away like that just what you want from
me can't be so okay the old one
creates because it's just this
resilience this toughness is in an
individual sport like tennis which unfortunately is
essential you can do it like that  be talented
like anything else if you do
n't bring this resilience with you this
stubbornness and also
resilience against pain then it will be
very very difficult in this sport
I will be more inspired Steffi Graf where that
Serena Williams not because it wasn't
Steffi graphically but I was ticking
too  young when Steffi Graf got excited so I
think I was around eight nine when Steffi
Graf stopped,
of course I noticed her on the periphery
but when you
start to notice things and start to
absorb things when I was 12 13
what Irina Williams  the icon who
became her first grand slam when i
was 12 had won her first grand slam
the us open
is just 17 18 years old and that was
so breaking mind blowing so
easy to see such a cool other
tennis player who just
rock n  ' Roll brought the flair
the spirit had that wasn't so
boring showed the emotions
that completely flashed me back then
and you got to know each other a bit more
yes
Serena Williams' favorite band is now
of course I can't think of the name um
this
this  Punk band that's so funny that's
their favorite band is
super well known dots
from America they also have this giant
[music]
hitsberg and we actually had
you Rolling Stone on Green Day
was on the front of the title and um they
have Serena and I over there  oh my
god green days my favorite band and we
got along really well i
played them for the first time once when i was 19 and that was
actually a pretty good story i
played them for the first time
and she was mine  absolute
favorite player i have always
followed her and i knew the only
chance i have to beat her is
if she i played against her in the first round
it if she is so
early in the first round of
tournaments she doesn't take her opponent
that way  serious especially back then so she was
maybe the most dominant tennis player there was ever and she did
n't know me and i knew that maybe she underestimated me and i
won the first one i led six three three three
and had in breakball
and played a stop  and she
ran over there then punched me
and yelled at me like that in the face
with her fist come man and I
looked into the eyes of a chasm
and I knew I was over and after that
I didn't play any more games and
then after every time  when she played against me she
had me on her
screen and always came
on the pitch fully prepared and I never
had a chance against her again no and I
also played against her sometimes when
I was already number 9 in the world like
when I was  was really in my
best time and Serena was
just so good that if she
wanted to win against you then she won against you
something simple it's
a bit strange in tennis anyway, sometimes
even though everyone is already world class
that the best are
different  are number four or
five well I mean that's yes I have to
say there's in my whole career
I've only had the feeling
twice three times the feeling that even
if I played my very best tennis
that I still wouldn't be good enough
to beat those three players
that was serena williams it was
naomiosaka and it was arena but lenker
who is now number two in the world
and she was relatively young then and um
and with those three players i
noticed there's just something there again  Are
there two more levels between
immortals, I'll say my
quotation marks now,
or is it just that they were
simply better in the sense that they
overpowered me I didn't have the strength
to fight back in terms of athleticism,
they were also able to do something with these
very athletic players
play very fast if you hold back well
then they often get stuck
because they then have so much power
that they can no longer control it,
they could control their power
and were also
strategically well trained or had
very good instincts you can do that
sometimes don't differentiate some
players just have
instinct and you think of them as
top tactics but they just feel the
game better than others and what
Sirena always had was she was able to
go into this other zone where she
was almost untouchable and that was that  like
an out of body experience that she
is in then go in and then you
just knew you felt it was such an energy
I played against her I
even get goosebumps
because I played against her
she was on her way  to the grand slammer she
had won the first three grand slams of the
year and was on course
to win the fourth in the US open
she didn't make it in the end she then lost in the semifinals
but i
played against her in the pre-tournament
and it was such an absurd energy in the
air I came on the pitch it was a
Toronto and she came and I had
played her five six times at the time and she came on
the pitch too and it was really like the air
was like  electrified although
I've never experienced anything like that and she had like
a huge ball of energy
that she carried around on the
pitch and although the Munster process was
n't over yet and I
already knew I've already gone to my trainer
so
brother we  going home today
the thing is eaten it was something
I've never experienced before it was also something
very very special this this Grand
Slam what's done in tennis
but I think this energy
of the whole year of this unbelievable
season that has played
out has  somehow accumulated there and
she still won this thing and
then lost at the US Open in the semifinals
okay so and then what do you want
there was for you the most beautiful or
the most important moment in tennis
that's a difficult question because the
most beautiful  Moment, I think the
most important moment for me was when
I was number 9 in the world and then
I had a stress fracture in the
sacroiliac joint, which
eventually developed into a complete
fracture and I was
out for ages and then I came back
and I  I didn't know if I
could still do it and many had already
written me off and the most successful
moment for me was when I
made it back into the top 10 so
it took me three years but
in 2014 I won the Antwerp tournament
and stood  then on Monday
the new world rankings are always published
and then on
Monday I got back up to number 9 and
for me that was the greatest moment for me
or
the coolest feeling of success I've
had in my life here because it was
like that  a bit of revenge a
bit I showed it to you that
was a bit of defiance but it
was also like that I had
planned and I had done it
I wouldn't have gotten everything
out so place four five would
n't have gone in the before  I
broke my back would have walked even more
if I had stayed healthy,
but you have to say
that it was my own fault for the injury,
I had had
back pain for ages, I just
kept playing because I
was in this rush of more and more
Success more and more success because when
I was number 9 in
the world in 2011 I was only 150 points
away from number 2 in the world, which
means that a tournament would
have been three rounds before the Austrian Open,
for example, I would have had one  difficult open
eighth or quarterfinals
I would have been number two it
always depends on how the others
play but theoretically if
everything had gone my way
I could have been number two in the world
it was my turn then
but then  after that it was the was that there were so
many grandchildren it was the limit
after that I wouldn't have
continued to write that your
focus was so 100% tennis far away I
also had a bit of
sponsorship chips I think you
probably had done a few things
por think  Me too, but
otherwise you were actually
full throttle tennis all year round, so to speak, who
are open to it around the clock, yes, I have always been
and I am, although I now
stand on many different pillars, but when I do something
I do it 100% and then I'm also
someone who I subordinate my
whole lifestyle to my job
somehow and
e.g. how I ate how I slept
how I rested what I
did in my free time that
was all ahem  Things that I
made dependent on my tennis career
and when sponsors came or
potential financiers asked me for things
that
would have affected my preparation, I
never did them and I know that
today it's a bit
different today
too  more back then, because the
tournament calendar was much more packed, you
played a lot more tournaments,
today’s generation, which I think is really good,
is playing fewer and fewer events and
is therefore of course a bit more
free in their calendar with their
time to budget, that wasn’t the
case back then and me  I then really
canceled everything that could somehow negatively influence me
in my sporting development.
You
said my other podcast somehow
at the time with Lorenzo
that everyone I don't know didn't have to
ask other tennis players tennis players I
believe that every
tennis player waits
and suffers from size in some way
and the reason
I say that is it's an individual sport and
you lose every week so you
have to  somehow
be an illusion artist and
pretend that you can still do it
so I always take as an example the
arms of my friend Angelique Kerber who
was number one in the world
because the number one in the world was
on tour for 17 years or she is now has
one  Baby will come back but
she's won 12 tournaments
so she's had an incredible
career she's one of the
most successful active players in the
last two decades really top 5
and she's only got 12 tournaments in this
17 year career and it's 12
weeks from  At the age of 17 she lost all the other weeks
that she played in tournaments
and I think
you have to take a look at that as a
tennis player if you still
think you lose almost every week if
you still think hey guys I
can do it anyway  you
do a bit undersize and
you can suffer from overestimation yourself you made friends with
the other players so exchanged a lot at the time it
was such
a high community first of all very
strong also competitors and a
bit anyway companies that realize something like that with one
so I always thought I
um  I'm badly injured on the tour and
I've always had friends and I'm very
good friends with Angelique Kerber. Jule
Girls, above all, my
German colleagues, with whom we
went through so much together in the
fatcup that the national team, yes, we
played finals and  well
i have very good friends also from
other countries in america i have a
few girlfriends who i
am still very good friends with who also
come from the tennis world but i have to
say since i stopped
i can feel the intimacy growing  how
real it got since i
'm no longer a current competitor on the tour and
it's up to me that i'm
not saying that the others get by
i think that's up to me you
just have a certain wall up if
you know you  can theoretically
play against a friend in two days or
against someone you know well and since i
no longer have that since
i am no longer a competitor no longer have this wall and it
has become a much more intimate and genuine
relationship you could kind of
Building up hatred
for the opponent and that is a strength,
but
if you don't see it that way, you can
imagine, but it must be the case
that you do that in the game, then I would be
so angry or have that kind of anger
towards the person  proje you can I do
n't know if hate
is the right word that I
used there but I think it's
definitely good and definitely such an
energy I think anger can also
be a very strong energy if you
if you  really bundles and um what
was always important to me, fortunately I have that because
I'm probably one of the
most proud of it from my career I
've always managed really in the
moment when the last game
was played the tennis player
identity was gone and I was back
Andrea again and I thanked my opponent
or congratulated her depending on
how the game
ended and I was always able to
tell the difference and some people
can't and I notice that it's also a
problem for them  Tennis players
who don't manage to somehow distinguish this
identity with the human being,
who
then, if they are very successful,
then also
identify and define that with themselves, but then
even if things don't work out that way, then they
also define themselves very much and are then
unhappy  with myself and
I actually mostly managed that relatively well
when I
was young at the very beginning not so much but at some point
I developed it quite well okay but
I mean and so I have the
feeling that it wasn’t that popular so
my first removal  we
also got to know each other here in Hamburg
at the festival but of course it was
relaxed there but if you had
scenes where they were really
unsportsmanlike wait a bit the
feeling that didn't work out so
Sirena is super moody, um  Serena
is she can be your best friend
one day and the next day she
no longer pays attention to you in the changing room
and um back then I
just thought she's great on her own,
I think she is too, but the
attention that surrounds her doesn't
really matter  wherever she goes there
are always people who somehow want something from her
i think it
creates an incredible amount of pressure and i was
there a few times in new york when
this hype was built up around her
and it's really an awful lot and
i think i know that  I too
have players who take their
worries or the pressure from outside with them on
the pitch. I was one of those and I
think Serena was too and it is precisely this high
stress moment in this high
pressure moment that things come out of the
subconscious that you don’t at all
where you didn't even know that
you were busy with that right now and um and there are
the other
players and there was Steffi Graf, for example,
one of them who saw tennis or the
tennis court as their comfort zone
and who all made of all the
things that happened outside
could forget the moment when she
was on the tennis court and it
worked best when the
world was ending around her because she was
in her comfort zone on the tennis court
and I think Serena was
more someone who
dragged things with her and then
when it was  a high moment of pressure was
sometimes just emotions came to the fore
that you no longer control in the
end always liked to play tennis that is
for me there are surprisingly many i
mean that clearly the famous agassy book
that somehow hated it
i recently read the sentence  from the
Russian tennis player who said he
actually only plays because of the
money then that was good to hear so that was
it has always been fun for me it’s
totally a great passion I
’m still further into
tennis in a way and  way
i love it um i still like to play a
lot i was lucky also
until the end i was
n't tired of the training the only thing that really
exhausted me in the end i had three
or four ops in my career and in the
end it was prevention  the prevention
effort was greater than training
on the pitch and that made me
mentally exhausted and I
had to get involved I was exactly on it I
only had to do two hours of exercise for my
knees for my back in the morning
mobilization my physio had to come in
and that said then  I
was able to train let alone
play a match and in the end that got on my
nerves and at
some point it took me a little bit for two
hours
it was just I don’t know if it was bad luck
or inability on my part but I
had a lot of injuries a lot of
surgeries and that meant there were a lot of them, of course
Construction sites in my body that I
always have to treat somehow so
you're a bit fit now so if I
mean I didn't hit for a moment
he's still, so to speak,
to this day you can feel the
after-effects of his tennis career if
you're really quite jolly and healthy
my body is actually that of
the 60-year-old person, no, I
got off really well, but I
still have to, I definitely still do sports five times a week
and always build
this exercise, which I also did for
prevention  with a
and if I work a lot now or
do a lot of TV shots that
go from morning to evening and I don't get to it
then I notice
my knees and back relatively quickly, but if I
can do an exercise five or six times a week then I'm  well
I hope not but maybe
that won't take two
hours anymore don't worry okay so that's
a little bit at the time of after
tennis so you actually
did a lot of things at the end of your career, so to speak you became a ZDF
presenter at some point  Columnist
in various media magazines
and you have always been, let's say
very very
well, I had the feeling of
giving great interviews
[music]
how is your relationship with why is it
with the media such a particularly
good question, so I went to the zdf casting
I had just asked,
I was invited exactly and that
was exactly at the time when I was operated on my
left knee cartilage,
which means I was just in rehab, I
didn't have any tournaments and went there
and somehow accidentally
got this casting  I somehow
got the job that I competed against
other
people who did
n't have any tennis at the moment, I wasn't the only one,
I wouldn't say, a moderator who
came from another area, everything else
was professionally selected, yes,
I also went through a few steps
wasn't like that, that's what
people think too, yes, she's an
athlete, that's why she got the job,
I went to the classic
casting and I also had to
walk a few steps, so I didn't
just
go there three, I had to,
so I was  At the first casting,
I recorded a test show,
then I had to go to moderation training, so
I had to be two more rehearsals, so
it was a process of a few
months and a few weeks
and that was covered in the phase
where I operated on the cartilage  was where
the prognosis for me was from the doctors
yes we don't know anymore if you
can play properly again and that's when I
panicked that I no longer play
properly yes that I at least panic
that I can no longer play tennis
like I can  it as I could before the operation
and in the phase I
went to this casting and then
got the job and that was a
bit awkward because I was
able to play again and then I
suddenly had both jobs at the same time,
err  we did that, the ZDF was super
accommodating and really followed
my tournament schedule and it was
somehow quite good and um that's how I
got in there but I think you
have a lot of things so
I think Sport Illustration will know from the time
do you write for or have
you written a lot so in germany there is
almost no medium where you couldn’t read something from
you
how did that start so did those who
discovered you have fun you
somehow have content creation if you would
say well i always have
written and i published first fun
interest first in america
i started a magazine with friends
called racket
magazine it's in new york and it
was supposed to
cover a big tennis and other sports racquet sports in the broadest sense but we wanted it to be a
bit more artistic  we
always have artists who discover and
design it only comes out four times a year
we always bought real
writers from the
New Yorker and New York Times
that they write the articles about
tennis so we wanted a little bit
David Foster Wallace was like that  a little bit of
the patron saint
saying that died 14 years ago recently or some time ago
anyway, he also wrote a lot or a
very famous
text about tennis and so
okay that's a world in which you do
exactly and um and and then we have
we also wanted to make tennis more diverse and more inclusive relatively quickly
from the start
because it is still considered
the white sport and we
simply wanted to bring new people in, young
people, modern people, bring in a bit of street
style and so on and so
forth  and that means I've
actually been writing
and publishing in America for a really long time, and relatively
early on, I think when I was three or 24,
I wrote such a long report
where I was on tour with a band
and the touring life of an
artist
dropped
chapters  From my book it happened
by coincidence that it's called tennis and
for that I was nominated for Best
Sports Righting, so in
America, strangely enough, I had just done a
writing courier in English myself
or
I was tennis you're already um well
I mean that would be speaks yes  also great
English I think in tennis you are
easy are these two big tours a
year at the beginning of the year in March and
then at the end of the year before the US Open
you are simply in America for eight weeks
and at some point when you are on the tour for a long time  If
you then get
half a place in America it does
n’t have to be like that I live in America
but I always had New
York as my base relatively quickly, for example,
when I
had long tournament phases in America I
always went to New York from time to time
gone and many tennis
players in Florida have a
special affinity for New York, look,
the German media have definitely
understood that you
can do something like that and then more and more people
asked and the SZ were actually the first to ask
me for a column
asked and they were
like that yes you can then
call one of our editors and he will write
everything down and then I said
brother no I’ll do that myself
and that’s how the whole thing came about yes which
ones call from which ranking  because
the watches partner on because actually
everyone plays tennis top partner
not whether that's confirmed I'll weigh
it up before I sit down here in
hot nettles there is a
dish that if you come from a good
market and Top 10 Rolex are on
everyone  Case is always there but I have no
idea I have
no idea I have
n't made partnerships
[music] I
rejected a lot, I'm
just wondering if I'll regret it afterwards
and I would say yes now, but then
when I was in the moment of the decision
I would have done it the same way again
because I was just back then, I do
n't know how it is now, but back then
it was mostly a brand ambassador
and one brand ambassador if you
're a brand ambassador then it's
time-consuming then they need
five presence days then they want to
shoot an advertisement then that's
all today  much much easier nope today
I have no idea because of that an x ​​sum
that I post on Instagram
that's why I have that that's why I
just used that no that's much
easier if I'm going to a poster now I'm going
to a party for ten minutes
it and and as a tennis player
nowadays you basically create your content
yourself back then when I played
almost ten years ago 2011 when I
had my best time then
these were spontaneous sponsorship contracts
were also very much tied to attendance days
so you can appear at this
press conference  can you
come to this event we need
you here as a spokesperson we need
you here we have to shoot an advert
in South Africa we have to do photo shoots
that then accumulated to ten to
15 presence days if you
have three partners it is not felt
but is realistic  one and a half
to two months that you don't train,
play tournaments or for your
sporting career and ca
n't, the money wasn't good enough for that and I fly
or what wasn't that
important to me at the time, depending on how you
like you like you then too  also
want to see and I think a lot has
become easier today in the sense that we
need five posts from you and you
can create your own content
we need real we need a
story and we need a post and uh
and no and it is probably
paid just as much  like back then, what you
had to cover with 15 attendance days,
in general, I have the feeling that
from an economic point of view, tennis is quite an
unfair sport in the sense that when
we look at how much turnover
is generated, e.g. at the grand tournaments, you have
already thought about it,
I know that  we tennis players
then earn only 7% of the turnover prize money
and we earn a lot of
prize money
so for normal people for normal
men the comparison is now
actually economically fair to
other stars who generate such ratings
which generate such viewers
and there I think  I
don't care much, look
at football or the NBA or something like
that, sometimes 60-70% of the
turnover generated by the respective league or
club is distributed to
the players, and in tennis it's not
there, the associations get it  a lot of money
or somewhere in the background tournament
organizers the players
only get a relatively small part of the
turnover
but you have already
liked it yes I think it has a lot
to do with how the sport is structured
so this this big advantage that there is
a  individual sport is what I
mean by that the big advantage that you
have in almost no other sport if
you watch a tennis match for two hours you
never forget these two players again you constantly see
their faces you see every emotion on their
faces you look like them  rauschimpfen
ne you watch two hours if you watch a
football game with 22 players then they
just show
Cristiano Ronaldo's most clenched teeth five times but you
won't notice the one player
so you notice really crass faces
if you take other sports Formula
1 the  always have helmets on skiing
always have helmets on ne so tennis is a
very, very strong, actually a very
strong, personality-driven sport
where you
can market the individual players super unfortunately there
is the disadvantage that these
players fight for the same brands
kind of
understand that but I mean tournaments
because I just wanted to
get back to it there were definitely ten times in
my career alone that there was an
attempt
to set up a players' union and it
's every time an  up to two players
failed other players who did
n't want to sign the contract and
the players were
mostly big stars and
you can do without them if Roger Federer he was
n't there now but I take him as an
example of course if everyone is trying
to play a tournament but Roger  Federer does
n't sign this thing, then
you don't have one, so to speak, because Roger
just revolves around Roger Federer or
Rafael Nadal or now Carlos it
doesn't matter the stars are interchangeable
but the stars remain the stars around which
the tournaments all revolve and if
they  if in doubt do
n't sign these player union contracts
you don't have the power
to enforce things and there's been
a player
union attempt in tennis for as long as I can remember and then it
failed a bit more,
put pressure on it and got a bit more
revenue  to demand for the players because
that really is, of course, we are talking
about hundreds of thousands, sometimes
when it comes to semi-finals, but who comes
to us semi-finals
and few people
and I, it is all amazing that
the distribution is still distributed compared to
looking at what is given to the players at golf events  is
paid out or as
I said in basketball or there are
players who sit on the bench somewhere in the NBA get
12 million in the year
because it's clear that there's more
money there, but then a lot more is
spent on the players and that's it
at the Grand Slam tournament I researched that
when I was in Paris
because I was curious then
you know what in Paris but that
makes I think between 100 and 200
million
400 million
sold around the world maybe
a profit then between 100 and yes  that
was difficult to research, but
just because the
television rights are sold in so many
different markets, then
of course you have to pay the ticket fees, then you have
everything, then you still have advertising partners on
site, so that's a lot of money together
in two weeks  and that pulls
the associations or someone but yes and
the crass thing is that, for
example, the two cities New York and
Melbourne host the two of these Grand Slams,
both times the two events, i.e.
the US Open in New York and the
Australian Open in Melbourne  for the
region, the top-selling events of all
time are the Super Bowl,
my New York was played and yet
the US Open was because tennis
is a global sport and for two
weeks people from all
countries come in and say
you look at me  three days in New York and
then I'll go to the US Open for three more days,
these are hotels, uh, going to
restaurants, so this region is
booming thanks to these tennis tournaments, that's
still to come